حسنًا ، سوف نتحدث عن
الأسلحة الآن على مدار 100 يوم
في هذه الحرب ، فقد تطورت أولاً الولايات المتحدة
وحلف الناتو أعطت الأوكرانيين الرمح
والصواريخ الملصقة ،
ثم مروحيات مي -17 وطائرات
بدون طيار من طراز بليد الآن مؤخرًا.  لقد أرسلنا للتو
مدافع هاوتزر مع الأوكرانيين يتدربون
على ما يسمونه
أنظمة صواريخ المدفعية
عالية الحركة والمريخ العالي الذي يريد الأوكرانيون
أن يبلغ مدى صواريخ المريخ هذه
ميل ، مما يمنحهم صواريخ
بمدى حوالي 50 فقط  الأميال يمكن أن
تحدث فرقًا بشكل عام ، وكيف يمكن
للأوكرانيين استخدامها
بشكل جيد يمكنهم إحداث فرق وقد
رأينا على مدار هذه
الأيام المائة الفرق الكبير الذي
يقدمه هذا النوع من المعدات للأوكرانيين ما يمنحهم حقًا هو
تصعيد القدرة على محاربة
الأوكرانيين لمحاربة الروس
بعمق وهذه هي الطريقة التي تحدد
بها الإيقاع التشغيلي وهذه هي الطريقة التي تحدد
بها الظروف للتكتيكا  أنا
أقاتل وهذا ما
توفره لهم هذه القدرات الآن ، ضع في اعتبارك أن
الرئيس زيلينسكي ورئيسنا
قد أشاروا إلى أننا لا نريد القتال
في روسيا من منظور الرجل العسكري
إذا كان بإمكانك الوصول إلى هذا
الملاذ إذا كان بإمكانك ملاحقة
الروس  حيث تكون لوجستياتهم حيث
يتزودون بالوقود حيث يعيدون
تجهيزهم حيث يأخذون استراحة ،
يمكنك الوصول إلى الإيقاع الذي يتعين
عليهم الآن تقديمه للمعركة ، يمكن لجميع
الأوكرانيين المناسبين ضبط الإيقاع